Війна, голод та клімат
Теми саміту G7 в замку Ельмау
Кращий світ
Тема протестів в громаді Гарміш-Партенкірхен
Від Москви до Пекіна
Реакції країн, яких не запросили
В ефірі «heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Наживо з саміту G7 у замку Ельмау.
Добрий вечір всім з баварської гірської ідилії.
Наразі це місце можна вважати
одним з найбільш захищених у світі.
Тут, де зачаровують ландшафти гір Веттерштайн,
віч-на-віч зустрілися високопосадовці G7 -
представники семи провідних індустріальних країн.
Навіть сьогодні не обійшлося без критики як саміту,
так і підстав його проведення.
Перед членами саміту стоїть нелегке завдання.
А все тому, що багато людей з нетерпінням чекають
на конкретні результати, нові ідеї, рішення.
Відповіді лунатимуть з цієї затишної місцини
неподалік громади Гарміш-Партенкірхен.
Своїх колег з G7 канцлер запросив
до розкішного готелю
з апартаментами ціною 650 євро за добу.
Він запевнив в єдності та рішучості.
Що це означає насправді?
Та що стоїть на кону?
Про це поговоримо протягом
наступних 30 хвилин.
Томас Райхарт з репортажем
про політичні акценти
першого дня саміту.
Розпочинається все
з того, що господар, Олаф Шольц,
спершу має дещо зачекати.
От-от зʼявиться Джо Байден.
Але де він забарився?
Це, безумовно, не входило до плану
ретельно підготованого саміту.
На відміну від синіх бахіл для журналістів,
щоб захистити особливо червону доріжку.
Зрештою прибуває Байден.
І, здається, Шольц з полегшенням видихнув.
«Наш саміт сьогодні
є чітким сигналом, - говорить Шольц.
- Путін, очевидно, цього не очікував».
«І це, звичайно, завдяки тобі,» -
відповідає президент США.
Для Шольца, якого часто
критикували за його нерішучість,
очікування виправдало себе.
Не тільки для Шольца,
але й для G7 в цілому саміт
проводиться для їхньої ж самовпевненості.
Йдеться про єдність в рішеннях
про постачання зброї, санкції,
про економічну допомогу власній країні.
Я дуже радий, що наша зустріч відбудеться
не за типовим регламентом,
а буде вдосталь часу,
щоб обговорити всі моменти.
Кожен зможе висловитися
щодо питань, які хвилюють.
Що, власне, й сталося
під час першого засідання.
Борис Джонсон завжди
говорить те, що його хвилює.
Тож він почав із важливого запитання.
«Чи можна зняти піджак?
Тут досить спекотно».
Прем'єр-міністр Великобританії
пропонує залишити піджаки.
А все тому: «Ми всі маємо показати,
що ми сильніші, ніж Путін», -
вважає Джонсон.
Інші члени G7, вочевидь, погоджуються.
Деякі політики в ході активних дискусій забувають
про всі камери та мікрофони, які чекають на інформацію.
Окрім Джастіна Трюдо з Канади.
«Відійдімо трохи далі від ЗМІ»,
- застерігає політик.
І не безпідставно.
Одного разу Трюдо спіймали
за плітками про Трампа.
Натомість Джо Байден
дає чітко зрозуміти, хто тут головний.
Перед початком саміту він повідомляє
про план G7 зупинити
імпорт російського золота,
який збагачував Росію
десятками мільярдів доларів.
Байден має намір також
реконструювати енергетичний ринок.
Весь світ відчуває наслідки
жорстокої війни Росії в Україні,
зокрема, й на енергетичних ринках.
Всі мають докласти зусиль та інвестувати
в проєкти чистої енергії,
щоб бути певним в тому, що,
попри зміни клімату, інфраструктура вистоїть.
Увечері вже без піджаків мова йде про
збільшення постачання зброї в Україну
та про необхідність єдності в рішеннях проти Росії
в умовах, можливо, тривалої війни.
Сьогодні з нами очільниця
Європейської комісії Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
Добрий вечір, пані фон дер Ляєн.
Добрий вечір.
Багато громадян не розуміють,
навіщо все це, чому проводити
саміт у такому форматі?
Чи почули Ви сьогодні
бодай речення або інформацію,
яку Ви б не отримали під час відеоконференції?
Безумовно.
Нам всім це добре відомо.
Після пандемії коронавірусу та нескінченних
відеоконференцій має значення:
зустріч відбувається особисто чи через екран.
Ми цілий день сьогодні активно
обговорювали теми та проблеми всього світу.
Ми добре знаємо одне одного
та вже спрацювалися.
Нас згуртувала, між іншим, жахлива
війна в Україні, яку розвʼязала Росія,
оскільки наша команда регулярно
зустрічалася для обговорення.
Особисті ж зустрічі й можливість
обговорити все віч-на-віч, звичайно, безцінні.
Ви щойно повернулися з офіційної вечері,
яка вважається однією з найважливіших подій.
І причина не тільки в основній страві - філе телятини.
Тож чи вдалося досягти результату?
Можете поділитися. Чи дійшли Ви згоди?
Чи висловився хтось відкрито та рішуче?
Що можете сказати про перший день саміту?
Важливо, що ми голосуємо, як саме
будемо опрацьовувати проблему.
Насамперед говорили
про подальшу підтримку України.
Цей список можна довго продовжувати.
Це зрозуміло.
Але чи є результат? Ви перелічуєте питання,
але як відповідає на них G7?
Наприклад, питання продовольчої кризи.
По-перше, ми маємо діяти спільно та фінансово
підтримати країни,
становище яких справді
критичне через війну Путіна.
По-друге, ми вирішуватимемо,
як чесно розділити пшеницю.
По-третє, тісна співпраця з країнами,
які повністю залежні від
української чи російської пшениці.
Ми маємо допомогти їм вирощувати власні
продукти харчування.
Щоб вони знову стали незалежними.
Тобто йдеться про те,
де і як ми можемо співпрацювати
задля досягнення цілей.
Як ви плануєте надалі підтримувати Україну?
З огляду на нову риторику
мова йде вже не про тижні й місяці, а про роки.
Ми будемо підтримувати
Україну, допоки це необхідно.
Це основний лозунг сьогоднішнього вечора.
А якщо війна триватиме роки
й знадобляться мільйони євро?
Ми все одно будемо підтримувати Україну.
Тут йдеться насамперед про те, хто переможе -
демократія чи агресор,
який веде брутальну війну проти України.
За ситуацією пильно
слідкують та аналізують автократії.
Чи достатньо жорстокої військової сили, щоб
порушувати цілісність інших держав
та нападати на них.
Чи переможуть демократії,
які з допомогою передусім
своєї економічної сили дадуть відсіч.
Ви згадали сьогодні багато важливих тем:
кліматична та енергетична кризи,
війна в Україні.
Я можу припустити, що настільки
напруженої ситуації ще не було.
Чи можна вважати цей саміт G7
найважливішим в історії?
Я не можу точно відповісти на це запитання,
адже, звичайно, не брала участь
у всіх самітах G7, які відбулися за останні 20-30 років.
Але такої кількості криз одночасно ще не було.
Ми тільки-но почали забувати про коронавірус
та відновлювати економіку.
Ми обговорювали ланцюги поставки,
які порушилися через COVID-19,
а тоді удару завдала війна.
І як наслідок  - енергетична, кліматична
та продовольча кризи.
Таке загострення криз нас неабияк хвилює.
Чим важливіший саміт, тим більший
ризик його невдачі, чи не так?
Що якщо саміт не принесе бажаних результатів?
На мою думку, все абсолютно по-іншому.
Передусім через нашу злагодженість. Ми знаємо,
що мова йде не про країни G7 та їхніх громадян,
а про глобальні проблеми світу.
Тож, хто, як не ми, має взяти на себе
відповідальність та ухвалювати рішення?
Приймати рішення, взяти відповідальність.
Та що Ви скажете країнам Півдня,
представники яких приєднаються завтра?
Вони запевняють, що для них ціна занадто висока,
вона вимірюється життями.
Представники Півдня
ледь зводять кінці з кінцями
та не можуть впоратися
з високими цінами на енергоносії.
Чи достатньо буде заклику до солідарності?
Ні, але я рада, що ми запросили представників
інших країн та організацій,
а також міжнародних кредитно-фінансових установ.
Ми серйозно підходимо до теми цін на енергію.
Ми обговорювали, наприклад, обмеження ціни на нафту.
Адже платити таку ціну країнам,
що розвиваються, не під силу.
Це була ідея Джо Байдена,
але чи готова вона для застосування?
Ми обговорювали це питання.
Наразі наші експерти опрацьовують деталі.
І це справді потрібно.
Адже не може бути так,
що Путін продаватиме нафту за надвисокими цінами
й у такий спосіб фінансуватиме війну,
у той час як країни, що розвиваються,
не матимуть змоги купувати цю нафту.
Тут світ має об'єднатися й сказати:
«Ми не будемо платити таку космічну ціну,
натомість ми встановимо ціновий ліміт».
До цього мають долучитися всі.
Ми гарантуватимемо справедливу оплату,
але не таку високу,
щоб Путін зміг поповнювати свою воєнну казну.
Усі необхідні кроки ми
обговорюємо зі спеціалістами.
Як Ви вважаєте, чи можлива участь
Путіна в саміті G20 у листопаді?
Зрозуміло одне - партнерства з Росією
у попередній формі вже не буде.
Звучить так, наче Ви не заборонятимете нікому
їхати туди, навіть якщо там буде Путін.
Я думаю, що нам варто обговорити це.
Важливо сказати йому в лице,
що ми думаємо про нього та його спосіб торгівлі.
Ми мусимо детально обговорити,
чи варто нам взагалі зупиняти діяльність G20.
Я вважаю зустрічі G20 дуже
важливими, тому я проти цього.
На мою думку, у разі приїзду Путіна
краще сказати йому в лице,
що ми думаємо про його дії.
І тоді він буде змушений висловити свою позицію.
На мою думку, група G20 є занадто важливою,
зокрема для країн, що розвиваються,
та нових індустріальних країн,
щоб ми зупиняли її діяльність через Путіна.
Ще одне запитання:
у цій гірській ідилії Ви ніби й не звертаєте уваги
на протести противників G7,
як-от деяких місцевих жителів.
Чи правильна це реакція на турботи громадян?
По-перше, поки ці протести мирні,
я ставлюся до них позитивно.
Ми не маємо забувати, що це ознака демократії,
яка проявляється не в усіх куточках світу.
Так, в автократичній державі,
про яку ми, власне, говоримо,
такі протести неможливі.
По-друге, ми маємо чути
критику й реагувати на неї.
І по-третє, якщо тут зустрічаються
так багато глав держав та урядів,
то великим здобутком є вже навіть те,
що ми можемо зібратися у вузькому колі,
щоб обговорити важливі світові проблеми.
Це була Урсула фон дер Ляєн. Щиро дякую.
Розмова була записана майже годину тому.
Позаду мене, у замку Ельмау, все ще тривають
обговорення, також із Урсулою фон дер Ляєн.
Навіть в ізольованому готелі на висоті 1008 м,
де проходить саміт G7, чути шум гелікоптерів,
якими летять глави урядів,
а також делегації та преса,
якщо вулицями пройти неможливо.
Поліцейські та військові,
залучені тут у рекордній кількості,
мають гарантувати безпеку й
тримати протестувальників подалі.
Іноді трапляються й казуси,
наприклад, коли під охороною поліції
зоною безпеки проводять 130 корів.
Є ті, хто зовсім не сприймає системи G7,
і ті, яких цікавить,
що зрештою принесе цей саміт.
Але світові зміни помітили й демонстранти.
Можливо, саме тому їх сьогодні
значно менше, ніж очікувалося.
Ютта Зонневальд розповість про це більше.
На висоті 3000 м над місцем проведення саміту G7,
на вершині гори Цуґшпітце, вони
звертаються до президентів та глав урядів
семи наймогутніших держав світу,
які засідають в долині.
Молоді активісти організації «Ґрінпіс» вимагають
миру та більше дій для захисту клімату.
Зміна клімату вже тут.
Вона не десь далеко, вона відбувається вже зараз.
І якщо ми будемо бездіяльні, то буде запізно.
Тоді наступним поколінням
дістанеться знищена планета.
Цьому ми хочемо запобігти.
Також і внизу, в центрі містечка Ґарміш-Партенкірхен,
вони хочуть висловити
країнам G7 своє невдоволення.
Сотні людей ідуть містечком
із класичними для протестів проти G7 гаслами:
про голод, бідність та глобальну економічну нерівність.
Але непокоїть їх також і війна проти України
та її наслідки.
Наприклад, інфляція, яка стосується нас усіх.
Нам уже зараз потрібне замороження цін.
Інакше нам не вистачатиме грошей на життя.
Дорожчає оренда житла,
також зростають ціни на продукти харчування.
Неповнолітніх попередньо навіть не запитали,
яка їхня думка щодо цих важливих питань.
Мені 17 років, там сидять люди,
які учетверо старші за мене, й обговорюють
важливі питання майбутнього, як-от зміна клімату,
війна, економіка. Вони дискутують про те,
чи потрібна нам нова економічна система.
Так не має бути.
На перший погляд здається, що питання,
які хвилюють протестувальників,
нічим не відрізняються від тих,
які обговорюють країни G7.
Так, канцлер Шольц як господар саміту
хоче запропонувати своїм гостям
створити «кліматичний клуб»
для спільної протидії зміні клімату,
спричиненої людьми.
То чому ж люди виходять на протест?
Уже певний час ми стежимо за політикою G7
і чуємо лише приємні слова
та обіцянки, але не бачимо жодних дій.
У цьому й проблема.
Тому країни G7 на саміті в Ельмау
мусять ухвалити конкретні рішення
й домовитися про конкретні дії.
Через таке обурення
виникає потреба в надзвичайних
запобіжних заходах:
18 тис. поліцейських зі всієї Німеччини
працюють над тим, аби протести не завадили
цій важливій події в замку Ельмау.
Таке політичне «альпійське шоу»
коштує близько 180 млн євро.
Ми всі пережили нелегкі часи,
зокрема через коронавірус.
І я думаю, що кошти можна
було б використати інакше.
Саміт G7 в Ельмау і протест проти нього -
це дежавю для жителів Гарміш-Партенкірхена,
які сім років тому вже
були свідками такого видовища
разом із масштабною
ізоляцією їхньої гірської долини.
Для Олівера Дебі та його магазину хокейного спорядження
це справжній жах.
Льодовий стадіон вже закритий
більше шести, майже семи місяців.
Наші продажі дорівнюють нулю.
Хокейну школу для дітей від 4-х до 14-ти років
ми змушені були закрити на серпень
через те,
що льодовий стадіон зайнятий поліцією.
Поки поліція стежить за всім,
що відбувається навколо саміту
у верхньобаварському Ельмау,
люди протестують далі -
у долині й на горі, за мир і кращий світ.
Панівною силою G7 залишаються США.
Навіть після ери Трампа, який із задоволенням
і подекуди занадто бездумно
саботував такі зустрічі.
До нас приєднується Ельмар Тевесен.
Ельмаре, чи зможе Байден,
який говорить найдовше, виправдати сподівання,
покладені на нього?
Адже в нього чимало проблем і вдома.
Байден перебуває у дивному становищі.
У G7 та НАТО йому вдалося досягти того,
чого не вдалося досягти вдома,
а саме єдності та примирення.
Тому він має утримувати принаймні єдність G7,
адже, якщо вона порушиться,
це буде допомогою
для Росії, а також для Китаю.
Для президента США втрата
позицій у внутрішній політиці
та невдачі у зовнішній політиці
означали б поразку, тому він має
привезти щось позитивне з цього саміту.
Чого варто очікувати від Байдена? Він саме
заговорив про ціновий ліміт для російської нафти.
Так, це хороша ідея, адже європейські держави
поки все ще розраховують на нафту з Росії.
І якщо встановити ліміт і сказати:
«Більше ми не платитимемо», тоді Путін зможе вирішити,
чи продовжувати йому таку торгівлю надалі.
Так можна було б запобігти його надмірним прибуткам,
адже зараз він заробляє більше, ніж до війни.
Державам, які не входять до G7,
як-от Індія чи Індонезія, ця ідея теж може сподобатися.
Якщо вони будуть долучені до цього,
то антиросійська коаліція розшириться.
Із основним принципом цієї ідеї
погодяться, імовірно, усі держави,
але про деталі ще потрібно буде домовитися.
Дякую, Ельмаре.
Санкції, Росія, Україна - такими були теми
й на попередньому саміті G7 в Ельмау,
ще 2015-го року. Проте зараз ці проблеми
є значно нагальнішими.
І, нібито для підкреслення цієї нагальності,
сьогодні російські ракети знову вдарили
по столиці України Києві.
Уперше за кілька тижнів.
Про президента Росії та його
послання до баварських гір
розповість Дара Гассанзаде.
Сповіщення про повітряну тривогу, яке майже щодня
приходить на телефон, перериває звичайне життя киян.
Але вже три тижні після таких сповіщень
не було жодних бомбардувань. До сьогодні.
Уранці декілька російських ракет
вдарили по Києву.
Вони влучили в цей житловий будинок.
Внаслідок обстрілу загинув один чоловік,
а ще шестеро мешканців борються за своє життя.
З огляду на масштаби руйнувань мер Кличко
боявся гірших наслідків.
Будівля зруйнована і ми знаємо,
що там під завалами ще є люди.
Вони живі.
Рятувальники намагаються їх витягти.
Там багато диму, ми робимо все можливе,
щоб урятувати їх якомога швидше.
Самовіддано та з ризиком
для життя рятувальники шукають
у завалах людей, які там застрягли.
Це біг наввипередки з часом.
Порятунок семирічної дівчинки.
Коли вибухнули ракети, вона спала.
Російські військові навмисне
запустили ракети по центру Києва,
у квартал, де розташовані університети,
ресторани та художні галереї.
Можливо, це символічно, атаки в ці дні.
Багато українців сприймають сьогоднішні авіаудари
як послання Москви саміту G7.
І як реакцію на це, українці очікують
подальшого постачання важкого озброєння.
Запросімо нашого кореспондента
Акселя Шторма з репортажем з Москви.
Тут, в Ельмау, немає жодної заяви,
в якій знову не йшлося б про Росію.
Наскільки уважно Путін спостерігає
за єдністю Заходу,
на яку тут неодноразово покликаються?
Щоб зрозуміти, що відбувається в Німеччині,
потрібно уважно подивитися на сьогоднішню Москву.
Для місцевих саміт G7 не відбувся.
Це тому, що політична верхівка країни,
Путін, не висловив
жодної позиції.
Але й тому,
що на російському телебаченні
його просто не показали.
Лише короткий репортаж
та й годі.
Політична супровідна музика
вже лунала минулого тижня.
Путін взяв участь у саміті між
Бразилією, Росією, Індією,
Китаєм та Південною Африкою.
Він наголосив, що
цей економічний союз є найважливішим у світі.
Цей союз, варто зазначити,
охоплює 40% населення світу.
На нього також припадає чверть
світового внутрішнього валового продукту.
Тут припускають,
що наразі ЄС і НАТО
створюють коаліцію для
великомасштабної війни проти Росії.
Вітаємо Міріам Штаймер, яка
розповість більше з Пекіна.
Китаю на саміті немає, але згадка
про нього постійно витає у залі засідань.
Як і думка про те, що G7 - демонстративна ініціатива
конкуренції з Китаєм
у галузі глобальної інфраструктури.
Офіційно саміт досі не відіграв тут жодної ролі.
Він не пролунав у вечірніх новинах
на державному телебаченні.
Всередині країни китайське керівництво
дуже уважно стежить за тим,
що відбувається в Ельмау.
Запитання в тому, наскільки стабільна
європейська коаліція, яка зібралася через Путіна.
Наскільки вона стабільна
у довгостроковій перспективі?
Якщо війна в Україні триватиме ще кілька місяців,
то довготривала перспектива - це дисципліна,
в якій Китай вважає себе непереможним.
Короткострокова згода народу
тут не потрібна.
Китай, безумовно, виграє від
нинішньої ситуації.
Він користується цим становищем,
санкціями Заходу.
Китай може в це тицьнути пальцем.
Росія, наприклад,
є найбільшим постачальником для Китаю.
На додаток
Захід цілковито зосереджений
на війні в Україні та її наслідках.
Це допомагає Китаю,
оскільки відсуває внутрішні проблеми
на задній план.
Порушення прав людини
або обмеження свобод в Гонконзі -
цьому приділяється мало уваги.
Загалом Китай зважатиме не на те,
що обговорюється, а скоріше на факт конкуренції.
На те, які дії будуть після обговорень.
У наших колег із «zdf heute» є ще багато історій
та інформації про G7,
доступних онлайн
на всіх каналах.
А тепер Гайнц Вольф з іншими новинами дня.
У зв'язку із зростанням витрат на електроенергію
та високою інфляцією канцлер Шольц
хоче запропонувати роботодавцям
одноразову виплату без урахування податків,
повідомляють ЗМІ.
Натомість профспілки мають відмовитися
від частини підвищення заробітної плати
у ході колективних переговорів.
На початку липня канцлер хоче обговорити
з вищими представниками працівників
та роботодавців,
як взяти під контроль розвиток цін.
За підсумками конференції Лівих в Ерфурті
делегати підтримали позицію керівництва партії
у внутрішній суперечці
про позицію щодо війни в Україні.
Резолюція звинувачує Росію
в імперіалістичній політиці
та засуджує напад на Україну.
До лютневого вторгнення багато партій
висловлювали розуміння російських інтересів.
Через брак персоналу в німецьких аеропортах
федеральний уряд хоче
запровадити можливість найму
іноземних робітників на обмежений період.
Уже в липні можна буде наймати персонал,
наприклад, у багажний відділ.
В аеропортах сезон відпусток розпочався хаотично.
Згідно з дослідженням, в аеропортах Німеччини не
вистачає близько 7200 кваліфікованих працівників.
А тепер - до новин спорту
На чемпіонаті світу з плавання
в Будапешті німецька естафетна
команда здобула «золото».
Квартет у складі Леа Бой, Олівера Клеммета,
Леоні Бек та Флоріана Веллброка завоював
титул чемпіона світу у плаванні 4х1,5 км,
випередивши плавців з Угорщини та Італії.
А на старті змагань зі стрибків у воду в Будапешті
німецький синхронний дует Бартель-Рюдігер
здобув «бронзу» за стрибки з триметрової дошки,
поступившись командам з Китаю
та Великобританії.
Сьогодні останній день змагань «Finals» в Берліні -
чемпіонаті Німеччини з 14 видів спорту.
Одна з найяскравіших подій вечора
з легкої атлетики:
cтрибки в довжину за участі олімпійської чемпіонки
Малайки Міхамбо.
Вона перемогла у змаганні на дистанції 6,85 м
і здобула
свій шостий титул чемпіонки Німеччини.
Наразі діє попередження про несприятливі погодні
умови від німецької метеорологічної служби.
Оголошено про сильні грози
зі зливами й градом
та шквалами в деяких районах Баден-Вюртемберга.
А тепер - прогноз погоди:
завтра на сході та південному сході
буде переважно сонячно і до 35°С тепла,
на решті територій - від 19 до 26°С,
рясні зливи із грозами,
локальні бурі з сильним дощем,
градом та шквалами.
У наступні кілька днів очікується
суміш сонячних ділянок та злив з грозами
за температури від 22 до 31°С.
А тепер погляньмо на
завтрашній прогноз для саміту G7,
Ельмаре, там будуть країни Півдня,
особливе фото готове за дві хвилини.
Фото, що нагадує про той момент у 2015 році
у цій особливій місцині
між тодішньою канцлеркою Німеччини
Ангелою Меркель
та тодішнім президентом США
Бараком Обамою.
Сьогодні цілий день було спекотно,
особливо для Макрона.
Тоді були безтурботніші часи.
З нами Ельмар Тевессен.
Сюди запрошені країни Півдня,
G7 не має орієнтуватися лише на Захід.
Решта країн приголомшені тим, що США
надають Україні таку велику фінансову допомогу.
Адже до них ще не дійшли їхні гроші,
обіцяні раніше.
Коли справи загострюються,
тут дбають тільки про себе.
Щоб зламати репутацію подвійних стандартів,
Західна спільнота цінностей
має виступити, почати діяти.
Я спостерігав за цим сьогодні,
6,5 млрд доларів
для різних структурних мереж.
Якщо такі держави, як
Південна Африка, Аргентина, Індонезія відчують,
що це можливо реалізувати,
це матиме великий потенціал.
Щиро дякую.
Сигнал рішучості та єдності має
ознаменувати цю зустріч
на найвищому рівні.
Це так часто підкреслювали сьогодні,
що вже одне це дає зрозуміти,
наскільки важко досягти
та зберегти обидва принципи.
Зокрема, стає зрозуміло,
що G7 ступає на довгий, важкий шлях,
що лідери хочуть взяти курс
на роки конфліктів і криз.
Тож усією студією ми дякуємо вам
за виявлений інтерес
та бажаємо гарного вечора.